McNulty gets a little too much positive
press very excited it was not often
allowed to eat pop-tarts this gel
you see pop-tarts every single morning
before going to school sometimes with
soda flavor items like they try to get
that like fizz aspect into the flavor
you know plan it never work Josh you
can't mimic carbonation they did a
really lackluster job on their swirl
right here it's to cursive ease is it a
crush pop tart this look like eyes oh
should we give it a little sniff it
smells like cardboard Oh orange soda no
my good no one has ever asked for hot
orange whatever orange pop rocks in here
imagine that also they've got synergy
there pop tart pop rocks pop rock cars
welcome at color that's one natural it's
pretty accurate I have to say they did
really good it tastes medicinal but nice
give it to me I immediately liked it
because their mother it was s'more mmm
oh my god you know what this must be
root beer if you just imagine a root
beer float but without any moisture
that's what you're about to experience
man you really sold that one man
it kind of works better than the orange
one the root beer a little bit of a
subtle flavor
you know the whimsical action in the
background whimsical okay one point
exactly the same it really is it just
tastes like the sugary part of root beer
check this out oh my god
is it good oh my here let me help you
with that with that nothing
I mean complemented so well listen I
think they were all kind of weird all to
him it was enjoyable but I don't think I
need to ever have it again they're
definitely thinking outside the box and
that's respectable
maybe they should just I'm keeping that
inside the box though I would eat the
frosting off of the pop-tarts how you
just oh yeah I mean you look like an
idiot
damn you fear terrible office